first up he is a CNN contributor former
White House associate director under
President Ronald Reagan please welcome
Jeffrey Lord Jeffrey you for having me
okay well catch me I wanted to have you
here because I see you on CNN all the
time you are nothing if not a steadfast
supporter of Donald Trump and you were
on the Trump train early 2013 2013 so
you get it you get to gloat but what I
want to know I feel like what I want to
know is this I mean because I you know
this is a small circle the media I talk
to people you talk to people the
Washington people like you come out here
everybody says you're the nicest guy in
the world
genteel polite what do you see in Donald
Trump get to me he's not just the most
vulgar politician we've ever had right
to me he's the most vulgar human being
right vulgar why do you genteel nice
polite they're funny lord have this
you've won mom over what is it what is
the attack she thinks first of all I
have to say somebody who knows something
and considers him a friend he has always
been in my presence polite charming
sensitive truly truly but you would
agree he's not that pub okay so some of
you but I agree that he appears people
in many ways as you as you described but
let me tell you up from a political
standpoint and I mean this seriously
when you heard the Hillary Clinton thing
about the basket of deplorable zand
people are here redeemable there are a
lot of Americans out there and I talked
to them a lot who think that people in
the media and the political world look
down on them and have basically contempt
for them and they look at Donald Trump
as somebody that can clap there and
stand up and dish it right back now you
can say that's right or that's wrong but
there's a genuine I mean I've been to
some of these Trump rallies and talk to
people and ask well you know what is
this and this is one of the things that
they really appreciate they think he is
standing up
them and they feel they just had it so
that's what she said one stupid thing
and that justifies was he grabbing no no
it's no no no I mean but again your
answer was she did one bad thing no no
no we forget okay I'm not communicating
what I'm trying to say is they feel this
is been going on for years she gave she
gave you no literal Catherine verse to
it but the business was going on for
years and years and years
with with people in the media and
politics of both parties I might add
okay but but again your answer is all
the bad stuff about Trump we let go
because we needed an attitude because we
need let is championed it needed because
the other side is so bad I have a
feeling that let me ask you this about
Republican yeah in general I think you
think that liberals are so dangerous
that almost anything justifies keeping
them out of office and that would
include the massive amount of lying that
I hear from your side and the
justification is that true am i is that
the real truth you think they're they're
feckless and their and their and their
fuzzy-headed and and they will sell this
country out not me all the time though I
thought I was going to be a liberal my
heroes were JFK Robert Kennedy Martin
Luther King and and then I began to see
this in college and I went on a protest
over Kent State to Vietnam to Washington
and I began a sense this is sort of you
know contempt for my parents generation
they've so-called greatest generation
and I really think that that is more
that that's Hillary Clinton remarks that
I just decided to you what's interesting
is not just that she fed it but the
response you hear from the audience
the cheered because they all agree
that's the kind of thing that I think is
really seriously wrong and you think
that's all because she said basket of
deplorable zits you know I think you
know the yesterday that Mike Pence was
using a private server basically doing I
was asked a quick way no classified
information house
right now he would act actually the lead
story in USA Today is Mike Pence is
using a private server discussing
intelligence matters homeland security
matters private matters I mean using a
private server to discuss public mantasy
pretty much the same thing they said
lock her up you think using the under
the surveillance of the or the following
the rules of the Indiana State
Government right but it just seems to me
like the way you guys can turn on a dime
about what you hated like three months
ago like using a teleprompter apparently
that's okay now but the president is
white talked about how Obama was always
using a teleprompter sure when but
whenever I sticks to it for an hour now
he's king mature they used to go after
Ronald Reagan all the time for using a
teleprompter idea okay I mean well okay
what if it used to be the free trade
people you I mean not always you know
yet right 1890 William McKinley Calvin
Coolidge Abraham Lincoln you turned on a
dime on so many of you used to be the
budget responsibility people and he just
proposed a budget where no entitlement
cuts defense build-up infrastructure
spending of a trillion dollars and
massive tax cuts for both the rich
people and the middle-class people what
happened to the budget responsible well
I think you do have to you know first of
all I'm just asking there I'm really
about principles it seems like the only
principle is I don't think I'm a name
and now the only thing in common that
Trump has what the old Republican seems
to me tax cuts for the rich elites that
you pretend to hate tax cuts for the
American middle class and the rich and
yes but but bill I mean this is where we
get into the difference here of class
warfare I don't believe in class warfare
well it is class warfare and you've
already won before you run any time okay
let me ask you my Russia because that's
the big story on everyone's lips
I'm sure you would say nothing to see
here because that's the Republican line
but then why all the lying why did the
National Security Advisor lie why did we
just catch Jeff Sessions you know I
don't think he did catch deaf substance
in a lot well he said he had no meetings
with the Russians and he turned out
again why did he recused well I mean I
read today again the questions specific
questions asked to him by Senator Al
Franken and Senator Patrick Leahy and it
was reference to a CNN story as a matter
of fact that was the reference and he
was talking about the CNN story he was
not talking about had he ever met
Russians period and he wasn't even asked
that question he just volunteered I
never met with the Russians and then he
met with the Russians wife why do you
think even if you have nothing because
he lied and he got caught no no Phil
Phil Phil look he's a senior United
States senators senators of both parties
and members of Congress meet with
Russians and other diplomats all the
time the Obama State Department sent the
Russian ambassador and these other folks
to Cleveland to the Republican National
Convention so the guy is there in
Cleveland at the behest of the Obama
State Department okay that has nothing
to do with it but well it does he
wouldn't been there anyways but
everybody seemed to event with this guy
I am see closely I'm just asking Nancy
Pelosi has met yes she said she never
met with this guy and now we have a
picture of him well let me have an
investigation at her because I'm sure
that but but the Russians didn't hack
Nancy Pelosi's election so they hacked
our election all of our intelligence
agency said for one side to win your
side are you telling me that if it had
worked out the other way
and they were only hacking the
Republicans to get Hillary elected you'd
let it slide oh I'm saying yes answer
that place
you have left that I would I would be
absolutely in favor of an investigation
I'm probably in favor of one anyway
probably but but I would absolutely be
in favor if anybody could show me that
the Russians govern to any voting
machine anywhere in America and that
nobody is that how you hack an election
bill no no that's one way you could hack
an election no one has said unless you
can manipulate the boats in the machine
well and I've gotten to see later boats
other ways let's not play games here mr.
Lord I like you and I heard you're a
very nice guy but don't [ __ ] me
there are other ways you can affect an
election and one of them is to hack the
emails of Europe of one side one side
and release those is a slow drip drip
drip I look and that's exactly what's
investigated not for it I'm for
absolutely but let's let's get it all
out okay let's I mean they attack the
White House I just intact every agency's
got no one could clear so much of what
if Donald Trump would release his tax
returns
why doesn't he releases pack returns as
every other president has done in my
lifetime it seems like a slap in the
face to the American people and also it
seems like he's hiding something right I
understand that the bill to be very
candid as I said many times on CNN I
totally disagree with it I don't think
he should ever release his tax returns
we've had presidents of the United
States from George Walsh Washington all
the way through Lyndon Johnson who never
released a single tax return which
Franklin Roosevelt the bad presidents
because he didn't release his tax return
I don't think so I didn't think this
dinner at this stage gear relevant okay
it is a political gotcha so not
irrelevant and you know which not
irrelevant be honest with me sir just be
honest tell me I'll be your best friend
he'll really believe it's irrelevant I
need all the best friends I can get
however I did respectfully I have to say
to you
that this becomes a political gotcha
game I mean if he releases they're
saying oh well you did this we need to
get the country moving again right well
not if the country is being led by
someone that was put there by a foreign
power now
I certainly would deny that you but this
is the assessment of the intelligence
agency you have no respect another
that's a assessment elevated the
intelligence agencies are basically
saying that the Russian government hacks
the dnc brand and and Wikipedia and all
kind of the purpose of electing one of
the do we don't know that that's what
they don't we don't know that's what
they said
so that's what the intelligence agency
said built and they should put out their
report and we should investigate this
I'm all for that
I mean let me ask you one last question
um Vladimir Putin with our Trump came
along had a 12% approval rating among
Republicans now it's 32 now Newsweek had
a big article this week that said he's
poisoned over 30 people and you know you
might say two or three but you know it's
kind of like you know Bill Cosby
accusers that like urgent I'm not we go
two or three could be possible but not
over 30 if you're like Stalin and
Franklin Roosevelt though you know
murdered knows we work at the Nazis
together yeah not doing that well I
don't if I want to know fighting Hitler
now know so okay asking yes this 32
percent approval rating that Donald
Trump has given to a lot of Mir Putin
good things bad said the story in
witters
two days that the bromances they call it
is souring I don't think that there ever
was a bromance I honestly I don't I
think that this is a again a little an
awfully nice things about him seven-year
yeah bill Bill O'Reilly said he's a
killer and John I think he's a killer I
put down with Donald George said we got
killers to fill kill
did you not read the church report you
know the central intelligence agent
doing all these things that the US
Senate run by Democrats in the day said
was bad behavior on the part of the
American government going after Fidel
Castro trying to put poison in his beard
and all the sorts of we have done
something I agree I mean think there's a
more I speak as a next liberal right
okay all right Thank You Jeffrey I wish
we had more time and Cokie come back ADA
you're brave to come here with our for
killing Isis thank you very much